[Music]
in 1886 German physicist Heinrich Hertz
made a startling discovery he noticed
that a spark generated on one side of a
room would cause another spark to appear
between a metal gap on the other side of
the room at the exact same time even
though they were not connected this is
because an electric spark creates an
invisible wave of energy that propagates
outwards in a spherical pattern and when
this wave passes through any piece of
metal such as a nearby wire it causes it
to vibrate electrically and generates an
electric current in the wire known as
electrical induction it was later
discovered that these were actually
invisible light waves known as radio
waves this discovery led to the radio
Telegraph the transmitter is simple it's
just a powerful battery which sends
electrical pulses through an antenna
whenever a key is pressed each pulse of
electrical current generates a radio
wave and far away on the receiving end
is an identical loop of wire or antenna
which is connected to a device which can
measure electrical current known as a
receiver
by the 1980s we needed a fast way to
transmit a growing amount of digital
data doing it by hand wasn't practical
to send digital data rapidly using radio
waves is a two-step process first the
transmitter sends out a continuous radio
wave we call a carrier wave this can be
done by sending an alternating
electrical current through an antenna
the second step is to send a message on
top of the carrier wave this is done by
changing the strength of the electrical
pulses at the transmitter between high
and low known as amplitude modulation on
the receiving end these low versus high
amplitude waves are converted into
pulses of electrical current and the low
waves are converted into zeros and the
high waves are converted back into ones
and that's the basis of digital wireless
and remember antennas send out signals
in all directions and just like with
sound when a loud siren rings everyone
in the area can hear it so with a single
powerful transmitter we can send signals
to many devices in a general area and
the signal will reach each device even
as it moves around this works because
radio waves can travel through most
nonmetallic surfaces such as walls the
only thing that blocks them are surfaces
with high metal content such as metallic
structures or rocks however when they
hit a metallic surface they bounce just
like light does so the signal can arrive
thanks to reflections think of these as
radio echoes
and this makes it easier for signals to
reach around corners from transmitter to
receiver and it's why we are used to
getting a cell phone signal almost
anywhere but of course in certain
locations the positioning between the
device and the base station is such that
your signal can get lost and this can be
caused by the unwanted consequences of
these radio echoes they can interfere
with each other
most often what happens is two or more
copies reach the receiver and just like
in water these overlapping waves
interact with each other adding together
to create a third wave the third wave
represents the addition of both waves if
the waves arrive at the same time then
the third wave is amplified resulting in
a very strong signal known as
constructive interference it's the good
kind of interference we run into a
problem though when the waves arrive at
different times this happens when two
signals travel slightly different
distances from transmitter to receiver
because they follow different paths
this results in one wave being shifted
in time compared to the other we call
this a phase shift if two signals arrive
and one is shifted exactly by half a
wave cycle they cancel each other out
resulting in a lost signal this is known
as destructive interference it's the bad
kind of interference and there is one
other case to consider this is when the
arriving signals combine to give a
signal that is shifted by half a wave
cycle causing the wave to flip and this
is also a good kind of interference
since the receiver just needs to detect
high versus low waves and so it's this
balance between constructive and
destructive interference that determines
the quality of the received signal we
express this using something called a
fading characteristic represented with
the letter H so for example if a single
copy of a signal arrives with no other
interference then there is no fading we
express this as H equals 1 usually what
happens is there is some other imbalance
of constructive and destructive
interference
so the key problem becomes how can we
combat the situation when H equals zero
in the mid-1990s several researchers
from the information theory Society
introduced the concept of space-time
codes it was based on the following
insight we can use multiple observations
to decrease the chances that we will
lose data due to destructive fading
first realize that when you have a bad
signal someone nearby may have a good
one and that's because different
environments experience different echo
patterns or fading characteristics this
is why moving your phone around will
often result in better signals so
imagine we connected a second antenna to
a mobile phone and separated them by
some distance and let's say receiver one
experience is fading h1 maybe it's
perfectly destructive so h1 equals zero
and receiver two experiences fading h2
and in this case it's a clean signal so
h2 equals one and now we have a better
chance of receiving the signal because
just one of the two possible channels
needs to be good in order to recover the
data so for example if we are sending a
two bit message zero one each receiving
antenna will measure the original signal
multiplied by the feeding characteristic
receiver one will measure zero zero
receiver two will measure zero one and
so if one of the channels has a nonzero
feeding characteristic in this case
receiver two then we can recover the
data the problem with this method is
it's not practical to rely on multiple
antennas for small devices the question
is can we instead use multiple antennas
at the base station or the transmit side
to mimic the advantages of multiple
receiver antennas for example using a
second transmit antenna separated by a
distance sending the same signal
as before because these signals travel
unique paths they will fade differently
h1 and h2 and this gives us two chances
to receive the signal correctly on the
receiving end with a single antenna
however there is one subtle problem to
address to make this system work its due
to the fact that the transmitted signals
will combine at the receiver antenna so
from the receivers perspective it looks
like a single signal was received with a
new fading characteristic let's call it
h3 which is the addition of h1 and h2
and so if h1 and h2 happened to be
perfectly out of phase they will combine
to form h3 equals zero erasing the
signal even though both of the channels
were good on their own to address this
problem space time codes were invented
and we illustrate the idea with a well
known construction by Ala mu T let's say
the message is two symbols long a and B
he sends two different symbols at each
time step so transmitter one will send a
be in transmitter two will send B a and
as before the transmitters experience
fading characteristic plus one and minus
one now let's think about what would
happen on the receiving end at the first
time step the receiver would measure a
blend of both symbols in this case B
minus a and at this point the receiver
doesn't know those individual values of
a and B for example if it measures zero
what's a and B a and B could both be 0
or both be 1 we can't say for sure yet
we don't have enough information so the
receiver needs more information and
that's what the next time step is for
transmitter 1 will send be in
transmitter 2 will send a and on the
receiving end it will measure a minus B
and let's say this measurement works out
to 0 so we know a minus B equals 0 now
we have two pieces of information but
that still doesn't help us because we
don't know if a and B both equal 1 or a
and B both equals 0 the problem here is
that our second measurement a minus B
can always be found from our first
measure
multiplying the first equation by minus
one gives a minus B so our two
transmissions effectively send the same
information in different forms an ala
Moody's clever trick to make this work
was to make one of these measurements a
plus B one of the transmitter needs to
send the negative value or amplitude of
one of the symbols at one of the time
slots alamou D chooses the first symbol
from transmitter two to flip using a
negative so transmitter one sends a and
then B transmitter two sends negative B
and then a and if we do that the
receiver will measure two observations B
minus a and a plus B and let's say for
example a plus B was measured at two now
the receiver knows for sure that a
equals one and B equals one and in the
other case where a plus B worked out to
zero
then we know for sure that both a and B
equals zero and that's how the
individual symbols and the message are
recovered it works just like we received
each symbol from two different receiving
antennas but using a single receiver
antenna this is an exciting insight
because it increases the reliability of
all receiving devices using a simple
code and one extra transmit antenna
increasing reliability is just one of
the many advantages offered by multiple
antennas such systems are now known as
multi input multi output or MIMO and the
researchers from the information theory
Society have developed the theory and
practice of MIMO resulting in a new
class of codes called space time codes
these systems have been in use for the
past 10 years and new approaches for
using my mo systems are being explored
for future wireless communication
systems
you
[Music]